so this is all fine but it's that simple
have a look at 4a if you haven't cast
her eyes there and let's try to unpack
this one your H is holding and disco to
raise money and then it starts to talk
about the cost of the tickets the cost
of running the disco and then it talks
about this profit that they want to make
$300 okay
and finally it says let n stand for the
number of tickets sold hmm now in
silence this time I want you to have a
think on your own we're just gonna do
this I'm gonna give you all about 30
seconds I want you to think about how
you would write the equation and I want
you to write commit anything to paper
right now I'll give you 30 seconds don't
speak I want you to think about on your
own jot it down and then in 30 seconds
we'll come back together let's have a
discussion for this okay now I wonder if
and I'm actually hoping we get lots of
different answers I wonder if anyone's
brave enough to suggest to me not their
answer but their initial equation Louise
you wanna start us off okay so hit pause
on that so you've got a you've got a way
through this solution the way through
the questions many ways but before we
get to that I want to try and flex this
skill of building equation that we can
then solve I'm not doubting that you'll
get to an answer but I want to see if we
can do this translation step Harry do
you wanna suggest
five an equals 130 plus 300 okay
so hands up if you had exactly the same
equation as hairy hands up so I see I
see three hands okay thank you hands
down there's a lot of hands that didn't
go up did someone have a different
equation they are five and minus 130
equals 300 okay did anyone have what
Leah wrote down as theirs okay
interesting way I have my hand off
because that's the one I had written
down did someone have a different one
again
yeah go ahead Murr hmm so you're now
starting to think about which one are we
gonna go for before I do have that
discussion we're all gonna have that
discussion I just want to are there any
other ones to add to the list with him
did you have something five n equals 430
Sal we went it okay good all right so
it's different all right anyone have a
different equation as their first line
not where you went just the very first
line you wrote are you just stretching
Louise or is that a maybe I could go
ahead is that what you have written up
yeah okay all right all right now here's
what I want to ask all of you I now want
you to look at all of them together all
of them together I don't want to make a
comparison okay which one's right there
all right in a different way right there
all right enjoy in fact I'm
interestingly as we wrote them all down
I think we're gonna get the same answer
out of all of them has someone gone
ahead and worked out nutzy n equals and
they 8086 do I have some agreement David
I think I heard you say 86 as well okay
anyone else yeah now I'm just gonna go
ahead and wage I'm just gonna double
check here I'll make sure to tie myself
in or not uh I think we're gonna get 86
out of all of these I think we're gonna
get 86 out of all of these right now the
question is well which one should we
start with now Marik I'm gonna come to
you now but
you had a thought about this you said
the 130 you said it was part of the 300
can you explain what you mean by that
the 100th is part of the 300 yep okay
all right now interesting I want to ask
Erin else on their thoughts is the 130
part of 300 if it is why if not why not
I'm interested in the reason okay Carrie
you're like you're like totally shaking
your head of me can you justify your
thought it costs time for 30 to run the
disco but I want to make a profit okay
that's you just said a really important
word there which was the word extra
right which I think isn't worth it's not
in the question but it is implied right
the word profit profit it implies that
it's more than you've got to cover your
running costs first and then this is a
thing on top of that does that make
sense in fact I think you literally did
that with your heads like it's extra
okay so in fact the 130 and 300 are
separate and that's why we're adding
them here Lee I think was it you who had
this one well yep yep why this yeah okay
fantastic so you've already worked out
hopefully since we all end up here we're
all different shades of correct here so
it's not as though one of these is
correct and the rest of wrong but I
think what Lisa was very instructive
this is kind of like money in like if
you're you rate you're doing this you're
getting people are giving you money
right five in for every ticket you get
five dollars yeah but then this is not
money that comes in it's money that goes
out you then have to give that to
someone that's why the sign is different
okay
now it's worth saying you would go
straight from this equation to that one
and then I think we'd end up here and
then we'd get to em okay but importantly
what I need you to really think clearly
about and this comes out in all the
questions so that's the last example I'm
going to talk through on the board
you have to know really clearly be able
to argue why it is that that's got a
minus sign or that's division or that's
multiplication okay